the rumor continues that kurt russell is
going to return for a
new reboot of the stargate franchise
i initially said that story was a load
of rubbish but might there actually be a
little bit more to it
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so on my sister channel um psytrek sites
where i do little edits from our live
videos but i also do
what i call quick and dirty videos where
i'll do a very quick video and put it
out there as fast as i can
please there's a link in the description
to go and subscribe to that channel it
really helps out
i did a video very quickly when this
giant freaking robot story initially
came out
the story in a nutshell basically says
that kurt russell james spader were
being tapped up to return for a rebooted
version of stargate now this does come
from a story back in 2015 when mgm
actually went as far as green lighting a
sequel to the original star game movie
and kurt russell and james spader were
interested a few years after that the
idea was muted again and apparently
again james spader and kurt russell were
interested in reprising their roles as
daniel jackson and
colonel o'neill but it never went any
further than that because according to
um roland demeric he said amazon and mgm
at the time were not really interested
in the moviegoers they were only
interested in the tv fans by the way if
you like the content please consider
hitting the join button and you can go
to sidedashtrek.com to buy merchandise
including this we want stargate t-shirt
that i'm modeling for you at the moment
we really want to push amazon and put a
collective boot up their backsides to
bring back one of our favorite and
iconic tv shows so please get in there
sight dashtrack.com now i talk always
took that to me that the tv fans the
sg-1 the sg atlantis and the sg universe
fans are what mattered and that's what
i've always been told in the last 12
months or so since starting this channel
by people that i speak to that work in
and around mgm and now amazon they have
always told me that amazon do not want
to hard reboot this series because they
know that would annoy the bulk of the
fans
but
apparently again according to sources
that i've spoken to in the last couple
of days there might actually be some
truth to this rumor now giant freak and
robert have no credibility they are
clickbaiters a lot of the time they
release stories that have no weight to
them
but they sometimes do get things right
now
oh well over a year ago now they said
that mgm were about to reboot stargate
with two new series they were going to
do an animated series and a live action
series
i actually started this channel by doing
a video based on that report that report
once i then developed the channel
started developing sources that working
around this actually it was a source
coming and telling me that that video
was wrong that started my progress
towards developing a little network of
people that i speak to
they told me that actually even though
this story was kicked around and was
considered again them doing an animated
series was considered because mgm at the
time did have an animation studio that
they were trying to push forwards with
that by the time the story actually was
released on giant freaking robot it was
already well out to date a new executive
producer in charge of scripted material
had come in and said we don't have the
skills to do that let's just concentrate
on one series let's just concentrate and
see how that gets on let's talk to brad
and get a script written and that's what
they then did
so
even though that story was old and out
of date it was technically true
my source is telling me that this is
kind of the same thing going on here
apparently james spader has not been
there's been no conversations about
james spade returning for a movie
but
the story about kurt russell returning
might actually have some weight to it
and
as i've told you before no decision has
been made about stargate moving forward
they don't know what they want to do
but like i've also told you repeatedly
amazon have always wanted to do a movie
first
the plan was always to get the sale
through quickly
do a movie to re-kick-start the
franchise with a big bang
and then move into a new series
mgm was that was not their plan they
were going to start a new series with
brad wright as i've told you again
repeatedly over the last 12 months
amazon have never been that excited
about the app the brad wright project
that mgm had put forward
and have been on and on about what to do
about it
now
amazon really do think about um metadata
and things like this they look at what's
going on on twitter they look at what's
going on facebook and so on
they really do care what the fans think
the cynic in me says that they care
about what the fans think because
they're always trying to maximize profit
but let's give them the due they do
listen to us what they want to do is
have a big splash movie they want to
bring back a big movie star and kurt
russell's star has been in ascendance in
the last few years since his the netflix
um series of the the father christmas
movies they've done so well and he's
really become very popular again
they would love him to return as jack
o'neill in a big movie now i know you
say how on earth could that work
well to be honest they wouldn't even
have to destroy canon of sg-1 nsgu and
sga particularly there are ways to get
around it and fans are very forgiving of
this sort of thing and
they look at what star wars has done
bringing back all characters like han
solo and luke skywalker and things and
getting those actors back into the
franchises and how popular that's been
and they wonder if they could do the
same with star game
now
i love carousel i think he's a great
actor i think he's brilliant the father
christmas chronicles the the santa claus
chronicles whatever it's called it are
brilliant movies um and i i just think
he's great i would absolutely have no
problem in him coming back and reprising
his role of jack o'neill but i also love
richard dean anderson richard dean anson
is great and he might also be willing
you can't bring kurt russell back as
sort of like an older version of jack
o'neill because richard dean anderson is
an older version of jack o'neill so it
doesn't really make sense so where are
we at well
according to my sources
and these couple of people have both
said that this is something that's been
bounded around a few times they've never
really put any weight into it but the
rumor does keep continuing to surface so
maybe there's no smoke without fire
again these people are not high up
executives they don't necessarily know
this for a fact but they hear whispers
around the offices
so what they're saying is largely based
on opinion but it is opinion from people
that actually work in and around these
projects so i think we have to give them
a little bit of weight
they're saying that they could
completely understand kurt russell
returning they have never heard any
rumors about james spade or any other
actors returning so it would be
potentially a cameo maybe from kurt
russell or
um the way the story works would be sort
of a new team
jack o'neill comes in at some point for
some reason you know there's nearly 20
years has gone by since sg-1 finished we
don't really know where jack is now so
that could be explained somehow
and that then
that would move forward into the new
series following the movie the first
question i asked as well was would
roland emmerich be contractually obliged
to return for this movie
now a couple of the people i do speak to
do actually know about contractual stuff
and they have told me not necessarily
roland emerick in an interview himself a
few months ago actually did say that if
they did a new movie for stargate he'd
probably have to return he didn't seem
very keen to but he would probably have
to return because it's in his contract
according to my source it wouldn't be
contracted for him to return for a movie
necessarily it would be if this
franchise was returned for a cinematic
release now amazon according again to
the people i speak to have no intention
of releasing this movie cinema it would
be released to amazon prime so in that
case roland demick wouldn't necessarily
have to return or he wouldn't
necessarily be contractually obliged to
so to be honest after watching some of
his more recent projects i think we
might dodge a bullet with that one
because i don't want roland enrique to
return
um i saw moonfall it's awful and to be
honest he's had a long list of a couple
of projects recently that have been
awful and um i have no problem with an
opportunity but if amazon do go ahead
with this idea and this project then
that would mean the brad wright script
and brad rights pilot will not happen
now
towards the end of the mgm sale while
mgm still had control of this franchise
before the sale went through to amazon
and they took over
mgm were seriously looking at brad
wright's script and they did a lot of
preliminary work including some very
preliminary artwork they also had
another script they were looking at
and they were sort of comparing and
contrasting the two
immediately after the mgm sale went
through
mgm believed that they had free reign to
move forwards with this project and they
decided they were going to go with the
bride right project and they were i'm
told really really close to green
lightning but amazon pulled the plug
amazon decided they were going to review
all of mgm's products
the chief executives in charge of mgm
then left immediately after that because
again i'm told that they believed they
were going to have free reign for lots
of projects as soon as that was very
clear they weren't they felt that i had
no choice but leave
so
that's why those resignations happened
amazon have been reviewing all these
projects ever since
that review is now i'm told largely
complete
and the stargate project i'm again told
is now in sort of a preliminary planning
stage where if there is a small team
apparently there's a little office
somewhere amazon with stargate written
on the door i don't know if literally
where they are putting together
preliminary plans um for example
if they want to do as new show runner um
if they want new director for a series
or a movie they would be writing up a
short short list basically a small short
list of who might be interested who
would be capable before they then start
maybe approaching these people and
asking if they want to so that's that's
literally the it's not only early
planning this is like pre-early planning
it's ridiculously early in the stages of
how movies and tv shows get made but
that is currently happening
that was just basically proves to us
again amazon are really serious about
bringing stargate back it's just not
going to be as quick as we'd hoped
so
if the movie plan does go ahead brad
wright's plan is
done it won't happen
brad wright will probably not be
involved in a movie
the following series however is still
complete unknown um and obviously amazon
might decide that all this is not worth
it they've got a perfectly good script
and piler all ready to go in brad wright
and hey maybe they just go with him
and amazon do have a working
relationship with brad wright already he
has put on twitter before now as well
that he's actually written a movie for
amazon he's done other things with
amazon so it's very possible that they
will actually just change their minds
and just go with the project they
already have finally just really quickly
before i say goodbye
the we want stargate hashtag for the
twitterstorm on the 27th of july has
caused a little bit of controversy
apparently a lot of gators that consider
themselves to be very important have got
very upset with sebastian who started
this idea who was one of the first ones
to get out there and say let's do this
they all were complaining that they
hadn't been invited which
but
that has actually now progressed a
little bit and another person that is
very highly up involved in um bringing
back stargate and actually spoken to
joseph malozy and a couple of others
have now insisted that actually the
hashtag we want stargate needs to be
changed they need to have a hashtag that
is specific just to july the 27th this
has exacerbated sebastian he feels like
he's being attacked left right and
center to be honest and he's emailed me
a couple of times saying i've just had
enough of these guys
i don't know why it's become a political
statement i don't know why the hashtag
matters i'm not really big on twitter i
don't really go on twitter a great deal
so excuse me if i just don't understand
these things
but for me the hashtag doesn't matter as
long as we're on the same page and we're
talking about the same thing let's just
get out there and let's on july the 27th
dump on hashtag stargate hashtag we want
to stargate hashtag bring backstage i
don't really care
but get on twitter on july the 27th and
just don't stop
we've got stargate trending on twitter
for the first time and you know it's a
show that hasn't been on our screens for
11 years so i find that amazing
let's just make as much noise as we
possibly can and please to all the
gators out there
don't fight don't argue with each other
don't make sebastian feel like a little
piece of crap because he's actually
trying to do something
let's get together and pull together as
a team and let's do something that
forces amazon to make a decision sooner
rather than later if you are new to the
channel please like subscribe the bell
notification it really helps us out also
if you enjoy the content please consider
becoming a fully fledged side tracker
you can also go to sidetrack.com and buy
this t-shirt or a mug or something and
when we do the twitter storm on july the
27th do yourself a picture wearing a
t-shirt drinking out the mug whatever
because apparently pictures attached to
the hashtag actually push it up the
trending thing a little bit further so
that's all good i don't make any money
off this i think i make a couple of
pence each one because the way it rounds
out or whatever but i don't really make
any money off this project um i did this
because i think it's important so please
get outside dashtrek.com and buy your
merch quickly because this is in what a
week and a half so let's get on it okay
guys thanks please as always stay safe
i'll see you next time
[Music]
you